par et bienvenue à tous et avant de
développer ces titres un conte de noël
c'est la belle histoire de cette fin
d'année
en bretagne une enfant de 12 ans est
improvisé sage femme pour permettre à sa
mère d'accoucher les conflits étaient
retardés le père a fait un malaise
tout s'est bien passé et la jeune
collégienne a ensuite révélé qu'elle
rêvait de faire ce métier de sage femme
laeticia legendre patrice veulent c'est
une petite fille qui sous des apparences
bien tranquille vient de donner quelques
sueurs froides à ses parents et à sa
grande soeur au lendemain de noël sa
mère ressent les premières douleurs les
premières contractions sont commencés m
17h40 17h45 donc j'ai réveillé mon mari
et je vais pas partir l'internet et qui
sent la voiture à l'extérieur le verglas
même les pompiers tarde pas à arriver
dans le hameau où la famille hague
quant au père il se sent mal alors qui
fait 12 ans prend les choses en main
jusqu'à la venue au monde de sa petite
soeur
c'est un peu un fait dire je n'ai pas
cédé
question qu'aux jeunes et vieux vous
êtes un petit peu sentinel un petit peu
mais bon ça a été le temps c'est les 5
gros vermine et de la vie dure en face à
ça le fait
une fois le bébé l'avait ils attendront
l'arrivée des pompiers quelques minutes
plus tard pour couper le cordon
à la maternité où la maman a été
transféré les compliments n'ont pas
tardé il y avait 10 h un moteur qui me
réussit et où va-t-on bauchet tout de
suite une première expérience
professionnelle pour typhaine qui depuis
l'âge de 8 ans rêve de devenir sage
femme